hi this is fresh talker quadratic
equations are extremely important in
mathematics but unfortunately they can
also be very confusing in this video I'm
going to present a visual and geometric
proof so that you understand the
quadratic formula intuitively imagine
you want to solve x squared plus 2x
minus 15 equals 0 you could solve this
by graphing the equation x squared plus
2x minus 15 the points at which the
graph crosses the x axis are the
solutions you could also solve this
equation by factoring into linear terms
if you set these linear terms equal to 0
you'll get the same solutions as written
in the graph when those methods don't
work the quadratic formula will always
tell you how you can solve any quadratic
equation with arbitrary constants a B
and C so this is a very useful formula
but unfortunately it's not often
presented in an intuitive way why
exactly does it work so let's try and
understand this geometrically let's
solve this equation first we'll add 15
to both sides so that we have x squared
plus 2x equals 15
I'll now color code each term each term
is going to represent the area of a
shape 4x squared I'll represent it by a
square which has a side length of X the
area of the square is equal to x squared
the term 2x I'll represent by a
rectangle which has a side length of 2
and another side length of X the area of
this rectangle is equal to 2x finally
the term 15 I'll represent by a
rectangle which has an area of 15
it doesn't matter what the exact side
lengths are it only matters that the
area is 15 so I'm not going to write in
the side lengths but the task we have is
we want to have the two shapes on the
left we want their areas to be equal to
the area of 15 which is the shape on the
right so how can we do that well the
first thing we want to do is we want to
combine the two shapes and lucky for us
we have one common side of X so we can
combine these two shapes on one common
side but there's a trick we're going to
use we're going to split the rectangle
of two X into two small rectangles which
are X by one and now we're going to join
these strips onto each side of the
square so now we have a shape that's
almost equal to a square so what we need
to do is we want to add on the little
area so that we get a square so we put
an orange rectangle here and each of its
side lengths is equal to one and so this
area is equal to one and in order to
balance the equation we want to add the
same area to the right hand side so what
we've done geometrically will represent
algebraically by adding the term of one
to each the left and the right hand
sides of the equation and this is what's
known as completing the square you've
probably heard the term in algebra class
but this is the geometric reason we're
literally adding a term to this area so
that we can complete a square and now
this helps us solve the problem because
what we want to do will simplify that 15
plus 1 is equal to 16 is we have a
square with the side length of X plus 1
and we need that Square to be equal to
the square on the right hand side
so we want X plus 1 squared to have an
area of 16 now one way we could do this
to have an area of 16 is we can imagine
having a square that has a side length
of 4 so in order for our square on the
left to be equal to the square on the
right we want X plus 1 to be equal to 4
we can easily solve this that X is equal
to 3 but there's another way that we can
do this it's kind of an unusual way but
imagine we had side lengths of negative
4 if we multiply negative 4 by itself we
also get an area of 16 so we could also
set X plus 1 equal to negative 4 and
that gives us our other solution of x
equals negative 5 so this is the visual
way to understand quadratic equations
and if you understood this I'm going to
show you this proof just in a more
general way which is how we get the
quadratic formula so we have a general
quadratic equation and the first thing
I'm going to do is I'm going to subtract
C from both sides so we have ax squared
plus BX equals negative C will now
divide by the constant term of a so we
have x squared plus B over ax equals
negative C over a this is very similar
to the equation we just solved it is x
squared plus something times X equals a
constant term so let's use the same
procedure will represent x squared as
being the area of an of a square with
the side length of X will represent B
over a times X by a rectangle which has
one side of B over a and another side of
X and will represent the term negative C
over a by a rectangle which has an area
of negative C over a we don't need to
write the length of the side we just
know that the area is negative C over a
so we want the air
area of the areas of the two shapes on
the left to equal the area of the shape
on the right we'll use the same trick as
in the last problem we'll divide our
middle green rectangle in half so that
we have two side lengths of B over 2a
well now combine that with the square
that has a side length of X by matching
the side of X and now we almost have a
square what we're missing is an orange
square and each of its side lengths is B
divided by 2 over a so B divided by 2
over a multiplied by itself gives us the
area of the orange square which is B
squared divided by 4a squared
in order to balance the areas we have to
add the same area to the right hand side
so now let's do this algebraically we
need to add B squared divided by 4a
squared to both sides of the equation
we'll simplify the right hand side of
the equation if we combine the two like
terms I'm going to skip a couple steps
but the right hand side becomes b
squared minus 4ac all over 4a squared so
that becomes the area of the rectangle
on the right hand side the left hand
side we have a square with a side length
of X plus B over 2a and we want that to
be equal to our square which has an area
of b squared minus 4ac all over 4a
squared so there are two ways we could
do this we could set this equal to
positive the square root or negative the
square root of the area of the right
hand side so we have 1 our side length
of the square on the Left X plus B over
2a will either equal the positive root
or it will equal the negative root and
now if we simplify the square root and
then move the term B over 2a to the
right hand side
why'd we end up with the quadratic
formula that X is equal to negative B
plus or minus the square root of b
squared minus 4ac all over 2a and that's
where the quadratic formula comes from
intuitively is that this is the area
this is the length that will allow the
square on the left to be equal to the
square on the right so I hope this gives
you a deeper understanding of the
quadratic formula and is geometric
interpretation thanks for watching this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Walker and you can get my books I've
written many books about math and game
theory they're links in the video
description